vincent blind test
28 20
bon
non alors le générique de fin sera
illustrée par un morceau de scratch
massive qui s'appelle garde sont au top
extrait de votre album qui s'appelle
naked voilà vous connaissez le principe
celle par équipes c'est l'équipe de
philippe katerine contre l'équipe de
charles berling d'abord et ensuite ce
sera le chacun pour sa gueule voilà vous
êtes prêts numéro 1
un point pour l'équipe de charles
berling brindeau caligula
bravo on continu numéro 2
on me souffle le bas
l'ancien soudeur
si insu a balancé way charles m'a dit
c'est pas de deep purple trail et bien
barré sarr de saleté alors qu'ubs a
lancé tu ne joueras plus tard quand vous
savez que si à soulager à perdre âges
des enfants donc mais ça il faut pas
déconner on ne souffle pas sauf si nous
invitait ne trouve pas ce moment-là vous
venez bien entendu vous faire embrasser
par thierry en continu numéro 3
allez
c'est à dire si d'ici deux points pour
l'équipe de philippe katerine
un point pour l'équipe de charles
galland on continue soit quasi
comment tu le mets cela qu on lui m'a
dit non car derrière leurs panneaux se
regarde la journée clair ils n'ont pas
traîné non je te fais confiance laurent
et bien que la maison pas dribbler
antoine ou bon donc tu connais depeche
mode il surprendra selon leur en référé
voilà c'est les années 80 tu connaisses
ah ben voilà je fais c'est bon on
continue de deux ses traits bagarrer ce
soir à vous
là
bravo ah oui là ça fait 3 pour l'équipe
de charles bravo caligula on continue
je comprends pas ça comment tu connais
pas ça c'est ton époque celle ci même
farina permet je suis pas nous l'état
hat est pas une le wiener connais je
sais pas quoi mais nice n'a pas la radio
j'aime bien les films j'adore
bon allez charles aussi la leaf est
normal comment tu sais
à
et des suppôts lingala 1 l'aurait
trouvée et la mère et aurait laissé un
peu plus tu as et allégeant les rangs
d'une semaine de vacances en même temps
on garde faune il a eu le temps de se
reposer lui vacances de vacances c'est
pareil j'ai fait là bas avec et staff et
je peux pas le dire
ah bon j'ai monté une boîte échangiste
au ski le tir c'est ce bon vieux légumes
on a du fort bien à toi ma gueule
d'acteur
non on ne souffle pas
trois points pour l'équipe de philippe
katerine merci nicolas duvauchelle 5
pour l'équipe de charles berling qui
bénéficie d'un avant centre
on continue
aulas
là où je me permets de te féliciter
nicolas c'est n'importe quel type aurait
dit il dit pape et toi tu as dit laisse
tout et c'est très bien se félicite on
l'applaudît
merci
tu l'as dit avant à la distance à la
famille du karaté loi qui ya des lois
respectées
on rigole pas bon donc je sais la fin du
par équipes c'est l'équipe de charles
berling bravo qui gagne
avec deux points d'avancé maintenant il
n'y a plus défi nous rentrons dans la
série de bons taux étant pour un
tournant et que l'on trouvera donc
maintenant c'est chacun pour sa gueule
il n'y a plus de voix là il n'y a plus
d'amis à plus d équipes on y va
attention à vous
m
sauf celles bravo philippe katerine
on continue à vous j'ai dit oui
on continue très années 80 à vous
arbitres mm
en fait pas de mal
chez moi les 80
et
oui les mêmes
le revers est réglé
qui sait r est ce que tout le monde
donne sa langue au chat
non on sait qu'on s'entend supplie dit
un truc pour finir il n'importe quoi la
sévérité ligue et là on sort mais
maintenant ça c'est fini
non c'était human league
et maintenant on arrive à l'ultra branco
celui ou celle qui va trouver thride
star énorme au moins pendant une semaine
jusqu'au prochain blind test attention
tout le monde est prêt on se concentre
pas évident ça pas évident
bravo nicolas about
j'ai bien joué la fin commissariat il a
mis tout le monde d'accord par des tec
ne prenait absolument cadeaux mentaux
voilà je me servais pour charles lemay
d'abuja qui met un titre facile pour que
chaque mois échanges illicites indiqué
aussi pour said
bon là
et là qui s'est fait hors cat a demandé
un petit tu réponds bah c'est moi j'ai
rien demandé moi lui qui m mais si ça
c'est gréco et belphégor